i'm dr clayton deegan and i'm here to
present to you today about methods of
single vesicle analysis and
considerations for their use in
quantifying extracellular vesicles
happy to join you today and i'm here
from nano view biosciences
we'll have a quick overview of the
presentation in this presentation we're
going to review
several common single nanoparticle
analysis techniques so some of these can
be applied to any type of nanoparticle
but we'll more specifically consider
their role in extracellular vesicle or
ev analysis
we'll then visit some example data of
how these different techniques can be
used when dealing with characterizing an
unknown ev sample and some of the things
you want to think about when choosing
which one to use for a particular
problem
i'm here today having done my thesis
research at doc at ohio state in dr jeff
chalmers lab and then i worked for five
years as a field application scientist
at malvern analytical servicing
primarily their nanoparticle sizing
tools in the zetasizer dls which we
won't visit much today and the nanosite
nanoparticle tracking analysis tools
which we're obviously going to talk
about quite a bit
and for the past three years i've been
at nanovue biosciences where we market
the exo-view products which are a
interferometric microscope with
fluorescence capabilities which we'll
also visit today
since i can't be sure how familiar
everyone here is with evs i thought i
would take a couple slides at the
beginning to do very brief background
and introduction so
what's up with extracellular vesicles
why are we here having a track of
education on this well evs
are presently widely accepted as
circulating nanoparticles
been found to be present in virtually
all multicellular organisms
which are composed of specifically
organized proteins lipids and nucleic
acids and these contents are very much
under investigation right now and
identifying those contents and their
biological roles has implications in
both diagnostics therapeutics and our
general understanding of how our bodies
function so these contents and protein
machineries allow evs to influence the
recipient cells those that take them up
their phenotype and they're under
investigation for both
diagnostic and therapeutic uses
so when we're talking about evs what is
an extracellular vesicle and it's a
basic level by nomenclature there's two
primary subsets defining these vesicles
that we will find outside the cell
exosomes those which form from an
intraluminal vesicle called a
multivesicular body and those others
microvesicles which bud directly from
the plasma membrane which are often more
numerous than those of the endosomal
origin but in today's talk we'll explore
the display of some common tetraspan
markers in those different functions
when we look at the data and also
examine some assumptions about the size
differences in composition that go along
with those in isolating them but in
general all of the techniques we're
talking about are appropriate for both
characterizing
an exosome or a micro vesicle based on
their size and physical characteristics
so
when it comes to evs you can use any of
these techniques for all of these types
of vesicles
let's look at a typical eb investigation
workflow at the start we have our ev
laden sample and in this case this can
come from a lot of different places we
could have cell culture media from model
systems is a common place you'll find
all cell culture media laid in with evs
plasma and serum are very common for
patient investigations other biofluids
like urine saliva and cfs
are often of interest and right now the
first thing that most investigations
require is the isolation of the ev
fraction or a particle enrichment step
which common techniques here this is not
an exhaustive list but ultra
centrifugation or differential ultra
centrifugation is a classic technique
for isolating evs from a complex system
very common today is size exclusion
chromatography size occlusion
chromatography is
in this mode particularly good for
removing free protein fractions from the
eb fraction so simple float over the
column your evs come off first and the
protein stays behind and elude
separately so a very common technical
procedure for isolating ibs and then the
precipitation reagents which are also
common for bulk isolation you add a
reagent directly to the sample and then
a low speed spin as opposed to the ultra
centrifugation speed spin allows the evs
to be pelleted the bottom of the tubing
collected and then from there there's
two
main workflows that go on for
characterization one is the particle
size and concentration how many
when we think of evs as particles how
many do we have them what size range do
they fall in and i have some little
images there of some of the tools we're
going to look at an nta tr a couple trps
machines and
the eevee and exosome marker detection
so this is often accomplished through a
western blot of classical protein
detection scheme um
flow cytometry but not with cells with
evs which we're definitely going to talk
about um dot blots
direct fluorescent staining is possible
you can observe the markers directly on
the evs and the bulk measurement i think
one of the distinctions we'll see is
that there's not often a direct
connection
in every technique between those
particles that are measured when we
measure a particle or we count a
particle and the assumption about
whether they are in fact the evs that we
would like to measure or not and when we
look through some of this data we're
going to see how that comes into play
so we talked on a slide or two ago about
exosomes and micro vesicles and and i
think it's important to think about can
micro vesicles be separated from
exosomes because things like cell
culture media plasma serum all of these
biofluids are
naturally laden with both and they're
very similar in in size as we'll find
out
ultra centrifugation in a dead end form
where we're doing the pelleting at the
bottom of the tube these are most likely
to come down together so they're not
really going to be sharply separated by
that
density gradient of course if they if
the particles have sufficiently
different density could obviously sort
them size exclusion chromatography in
setups which remove protein from the evs
wherein we can think of the evs as being
eluded in almost a void fraction at the
front of the column
when the protein stays behind in these
setups this is not likely to give
resolution to the nanoparticle setup and
precipitation no again if you take the
whole sample and precipitate it it's
likely all of these particles come out
in in one mixture so differentiating
them analyzing them that may or may not
be of importance to your study but it's
important to consider that when we look
at our results later they're probably
laden with both of these types of
particles in many of these samples
so what type of surface markers could be
used to differentiate them you know when
we think of exosomes versus
microvesicles the size of exosomes
certainly smaller although we're going
to find that the
these seeming envies can be
similar ranges and
the origin we discuss
that mechanism of formation and
right now you know distinct surface
markers for separating them
aren't
widely available but for more
information on the totality of ev
characterization you can always refer to
myself the minimum information for the
submission of extracellular vesicle
information which for publication style
work lays out the expected
characterization level depending on the
research question that's being
investigated so
if you have any questions check out the
myself resources they have a lot of
information on exactly what information
you should include
based on the type of data you want to
publish and with this kind of background
done let's now get into more specifics
about the techniques that we might
commonly encounter
for characterizing evs
this is a larger slide but this brings
in right away the five techniques that
we're going to discuss today and this is
going to focus on particle sizing and
counting but also some of these
techniques will offer the opportunity
for phenotyping so in a way we can cover
a lot of physical characterization of
how many particles what size of the
particles and what type of signals are
they carrying with a combination of
these techniques so from the top
nanoparticle tracking analysis and we'll
visit each of these for a more in-depth
discussion on how they work and then
we'll see some example data but nta
probably one of the most common tools
that you'll see used in the publications
for
characterizing evs for sizing count the
sample form that's required a key
consideration looking at 200 microliters
to a mill
with a concentration of approximately
one times ten to the eighth during the
measurement so for many people this can
require dilution or concentration
depending on the nature of the sample
but you tune the sample to about one
times ten to the eighth and then inject
it in the machine and the parameters you
can gather there are size
concentrations certainly and there are
publications in the literature for
particular samples wherein utilizing a
fluorescent tagging and then tracking
the fluorescently tagged particles can
realize a phenotype for a subset of the
particles that are observed in the
sizing mode although
there are some difficulties with
preparing samples and or having enough
signal per particle
to gather that information regularly
the detection mechanism fundamentally is
a light scattering mechanism so it's
related to the
art of the sixth the sixth power
function of the radius of the particle
doing the scattering and we'll write
that in there because later on we'll see
some
resolution between
the different techniques in terms of
when you have a mixture of nanoparticles
as opposed to a single size does that
resolving power of the
types of techniques that have
less influence with radius become useful
second line resistive pulse sensing
another very common instrument used for
sizing and counting nanoparticles
now here sample forms in an electrolyte
buffer it's a voltage driven so you need
an electrolyte buffer we'll discuss more
about the exact technique but
similar volume range and concentration
range to nta these two techniques make
orthogonal data by sampling
the sample itself from two different
ways we've got one's going to be voltage
driven one's going to be imaging driven
electron microscopy sample forms dried
on grids
when it comes to parameters you're
certainly gathering the size the dried
morphology maybe the classic cup shape
of the exosomes phenotyping is sometimes
reported using immunogold labeling so
it's a possibility and obviously driven
by electron density for the detection
mechanism we all know that em is still
probably considered the gold standard
for what is the edge to edge size of the
evs because you visualize them and we'll
we'll visit that later
flow cytometry is a common technique
there are many publications and we'll
discuss in a little more depth what some
of the caveats are certainly as a tool
it's very useful you can gather a lot of
phenotyping
information you can certainly gather
concentration of particles the way you
would do cells when we talk about size
put in range and i think that's the
biggest question when you're
implementing a flow cytometry protocol
in the context of an investigation is
how do you understand exactly what
particles you're sensitive to on your
system and that's what we'll discuss
regarding flow cytometry this is again a
light scattering
r6 type function for
detection so different particles of
different sizes are going to have a six
power function for their detectability
and then fluorescence obviously
available phenotyping is a key part of
flow cytometry
and then interferometric imaging is a
newer technique where the sample in is
in its original form during the the
capture step uh but it's diluted and
captured on a
immuno functionalized chip and then
dried so the analysis is more like tem
for the sizing at the end the with the
final analysis and you get size
phenotype and investigating
concentration it's a binding assay there
are ways to
do something about the concentration and
then interference is actually an r3
power so third power function of the
radius
and that
again we'll look at resolving power
peak-to-peak resolution when it comes to
the difference between the r6
and the r3 function methods and
fluorescence is a big part of the
interferometric imaging
so let's dive in a little deeper
nta nanoparticle tracking analysis we
see this video down below this is direct
data this is exactly what you can
observe with your eyes when you're
operating uh nanoparticle tracking
analysis tool you can see the particles
themselves
we can watch them move under brownian
motion so the vibrational nature of
their random walk there is the brownian
motion component we're inducing a flow
from the left so you can clearly see the
particles drift from the left to the
right of the screen that's on purpose
and all that does is increase the
sampling during the measurement so we
have more particles composing the size
distribution that we want to report
the entire
sizing is driven by the equation that's
presented here the 2d stokes einstein
equation so in nta we measure the mean
square displacement the xy squared
kb is boltzmann constant temperature is
either uh
measured and entered or observed by the
instrument uh rh
hydrodynamic radius that's the parameter
we're gonna extract from this and we see
the viscosity sitting at the end the
last thing we need to do so we'll talk
about that on the next page but
essentially you measure the mean square
displacement per particle and you
extract the rh information from this
equation when you use an nta system so
particles are observed vibrating take a
video
software determines the mean squared
displacement and out pops the data on
the right which is directly related to
this sample this video produced the data
on the right these are a liposome sample
so monodisperse and they're
we get a mean mode size distribution so
the means 93 the mode is 86 when we have
a mono dispersed distribution and use
the nta and count subtle differences in
the peak shape like that that's
revealing for the real number
distribution shape of this sample and
then
d10 d50 d90 are number weighted
number of particles below and
probably the most
interesting parameter that can be
extracted for any nanoparticle solution
by nta the concentration and that's
driven by
when we watch the particles move how
many particles per frame are being
interrogated
and then an assumption about the viewing
volume how big is the box that's been
illuminated that we're looking in so we
use the laser sourcing camera to record
the particles moving the particle tracks
determine the size distribution
and then the particle count is driven by
that estimation of viewing volume and it
comes out as a nice distribution where
the area under the curve represents the
total particles and you receive the
concentration number with it so what are
the key considerations when thinking
about using nta
to measure your samples so
one the sizing accuracy is going to
depend on buffer viscosity accuracy so
anytime you're using a non-water
solution you're going to want to account
for the viscosity accurately either with
a calibration so you can take a bead of
known size put it in the buffer and
observe the change in size to infer the
actual viscosity of the buffer or
a measurement and a temperature
controlled environment
be the biggest consideration for many
investigations is the nta is a
nanoparticle sizing tool the particles i
just showed you were liposomes so they
actually are only composed of lipid and
or monodisperse
when we have evs which are naturally
heterogeneous non-gaussian distribution
shapes and have a somewhat unknown lower
size limit nt is sensitive to particles
that aren't eb so you have to bear in
mind your sample prep possible
contaminants and running controls
without the ev portion of the prep
present to understand whether it's safe
to look at every particle in your nta
measurement as a potential ev or if it's
likely that only a fraction of them are
actually evs
and when you're talking about sizing and
resolution
gathering enough particle tracks for
sufficient statistics is really
important with nta low track numbers
will inherently give spiky distributions
and you can increase concentration so
dilute the sample less or gather longer
or more video measurements and aim for
about 500 valid tracks per 30 second
video
when you're using the syringe pump to
get a really nice
representative distribution
next technique trps
fairly simple in principle um and
operationally resistive pulse sensing
instruments are single nanoparticle
sizing and counting tools which can be
used for ev characterize
characterization so again they're
sensitive to any type of nanoparticle
that has that can induce a voltage
change while it crosses the nanopore
and during a trps measurement the sample
is diluted to a similar range to nta to
prevent coincidence and then as single
particles cross the particular nanopore
that's on the instrument a change in the
resistance across the pore is observed
and that is correlatable to the size of
the particle based on the solution and
particle properties and this is another
technique you're going to see commonly
reported in the literature to report the
size distribution and the counting of
particles in an ev prep
the key considerations with trps are
similar to nta some points you want to
keep in mind are the sizing sensitivity
is pore size dependent so
if you have the pore for the 100
nanometer particles you'll sense all of
those which are above that but none of
those which are below
and when you go up in size again you're
going to have a higher size cutoff so
combining data from different pore sizes
or being aware of the
seeming hard cut off in the size
sensitivity is important when you're
bringing together the data from from the
trps instrument
trps like nta is sensitive to
nanoparticles in general this is a
useful tool for counting any type of
particle prep so keeping in mind sample
preparation and potential contaminants
when interpreting the data
combining data from multiple pore size
measurements can reveal a more complete
picture with trps as we mentioned about
the size and sensitivity
we're going to skip em i think everyone
here has a concept of how electron
microscopy can take pictures of very
small objects and it's a direct
interrogation of of the
evs on the grid so we'll go to flow
cytometry and this is certainly a
surface dive of flow cytometry flow
cytometry is a very broad large research
field with applications that are
much more numerous than eb's outside of
evs so
not the primary field fluorescentometers
are used for but you're going to find in
the literature they're very common so
basic background on the flow cytometry
setup is is a laser numerous lasers
intersect the path of the particles as
they flow through the system and
when a particular sequence of signals is
gathered particularly on the forward and
side scatter in scatter triggering cases
so the particle passes the laser and
triggers above the desired level on the
forward and side scatter or in the
appropriate gate then the fluorescent
signals in the other channels will be
gathered and assigned for that particle
and this is
common classical work for cells used to
phenotype cells all over all the time
and with evs we run into
when using a conventional flow cytometer
issues with calibrating against
particles and inferring that the ev size
is the same as the particle
and
that's the main
topic that i want to touch on here is is
reporting the size
from
a calibration bead and how you how there
is good literature and help to go about
that to help you use whatever flow
cytometer you have available to you and
understand what its detection
capabilities really are for your sample
so that you're reporting confidently
what the equivalent particle size you've
measured is and what the equivalent
fluorescence intensity measured is so
on the right we see these two traces and
these are not particularly easy to read
in a quick presentation like this but
these are uh taken from publication by
edwin vanderpull and these are the
scattering intensity traces for
different types of particles and the big
takeaway here is is an a
where the lines intersect at the right
angle
we're intersecting the lines of
the polystyrene beads
the data for the polystyrene so black
dots over black line so that's a
polystyrene calibration bead from 100
200 250 500 nanometers up to eight 900
nanometers being run through the flow
cytometer and its direct scattering
signal detected and the theory and the
polystyrene data fit really nice and
then in the red line we can do the same
with silica
when we look at particles that have
ev-like properties in terms of their
optical properties
the green trace at the bottom of that
chart develops and that's the detection
range for evs at equivalent scattering
signal
to the calibration beads of somewhat
larger sizes and we can see that in this
example the detectability of evs below
200 nanometers where the green trace
falls below
the zero line
is not particularly likely when it comes
to using the scatter gates to detect the
exact dbs you would like and
this
is captured in our considerations for
flow cytometry
mainly the acid development for your
particular samples is a critical part of
any ev or not flow assay and this is no
different with ev so so understanding
what your ass has been developed to do
and what it detects is absolutely key
the detection capabilities of your
particular system should be thoroughly
determined for absolute quantification
and you can see the literature from
edwin vanderpolen josh welch for a deep
discussion on this topic and reference
my flow mi flow site so microflow
cytometry gives a lot of good guiding on
that sample preparation and removal of
unround labels becomes critical in flow
cytometry setups so potential for
extracting phenotype information is much
higher
and thus those are common aspects
labeling needing to clean up the labels
so
have to be able to handle that
interferometric imaging our last
technique for the deep dive here is an
immunoassay so the the little chip in
the bottom right where we see the single
18 number chip that's a that's a
full-size chip in in in the cartoon
image spotted in the middle of that is
this array of tetra spanning capture so
right off the bat we see interferometric
imaging is a positive selection
technique so you're gonna you can only
measure the particles which you pull
down anti-tetraspan and antibodies are
arrayed on the chip the chips incubated
with ev containing sample to allow
mobilization on the chip and after ev
capture
we incubate a cocktail of antibodies cd
81 63 and 9 for example with different
fluorescent conjugates
on top of the
now captured evs after washing away the
free ones then we wash away the free
label and then
chips dried and three color sequential
imaging has very strong single binding
event sensitivity revealing a lot of the
small eb's capture on the chip and also
is able to size in a label free mode so
gathering phenotype information big part
of the interferometric imaging
and
also provide size through single
particle interferometric reflectance
imaging and in the setup we see
implemented previous reports in the
range of 50 to 200 nanometers
and
in brief the chip structure allows for
the light to be passed through the
sample into the middle of the chip and
returned up to the
sensor and when particles are sitting on
top of the chip surface that weren't
present before they leave behind the
contrast signal and in this range we use
the contrast that develops to measure
the particle size
so direct imaging something closer to em
we'll see in a couple slides how that
comes together
so how does one measure an ev you know
we've seen these different techniques it
seems like a lot of them measure size
and concentration and so
basically
nanoparticle tracking analysis simple
common widely reported in the literature
provides a measurement of size and
concentration
specificities protocol dependent
whether you're seeing all evs or not
sensitive to non-eb particles in the
somewhat variable lower limit of
detection
got resistive pulse sensing simple
common widely reported in the literature
provides measurement of size and
concentration
it also sensitive to non-ev particles
the buffer can have an influence on the
sizing and sensitivity variations with
poor poor size choice
and clogging
em
honestly pros for em are still probably
considered the gold standard for what is
the size of the particle
relatively common to access at many
institutions
different system capabilities
it ev it can be technically challenging
to measure evs using em and uh sample
preparation is important
pros for flow cytometry again common
access you find access to a flow
cytometer robust literature dedicated to
evs i touched some we really made a
surface level interaction here and
opportunity for ev phenotyping so
gathering that data on what's on the
surface of evs
the con is that the different equipments
you might encounter can have very
different sensitivities
method development is a very important
part of the flow cytometry investigation
and know-how is required
and interferometric imaging or sp iris
has high resolution nanoparticle sizing
and allows detection of other markers on
single evs and combine size and
phenotype with multi-marker resolution
cons positive selection
can characterize those particles which
you capture cannot characterize those
which are not captured
longer sample preparation time getting
it ready
so let's take a quick look at some data
and see how this different information
comes together
right off the bat nta and tpr trps for
sample size and count
do you need one both different these two
techniques are fundamentally very
similar but make for good orthogonal
measurements of total particle count so
if you're developing something where you
must know the particle count
using both is probably a good idea and
i've shown some data on the right where
csf derived dbs are tested on both
systems and overall sometimes nta is
higher sometimes trps higher the authors
conclude that both give a representative
picture of the nanoparticle count and
size and the range that they're
sensitive to
so nta or crps
here let's visit some tem and spi
resizing results and there's
there's a lot of to this chart in this
work from dan bichersky's lab but this
is a really nice figure that provides a
normalized comparison of the detected ev
sizes so absent the counting aspect
there's four columns here and
some different types of samples we see
the 10k versus 100k evs for the two
different types of samples and we want
to point out there that
the 10k versus 100k regardless of what
technique you used
doesn't really show a difference in the
sample so that calls back to the
microvesicle exosome size difference and
then we see actually that the tem
and the sp iris data or marked xov here
in the right column when we look in the
full overlay we see the traces for the
two different nta instruments the gold
and black traces are very similar and
shifted to bigger sizes and our sp iris
and tem sizes are all
right down over each other at the
smaller ev sizes so
different techniques
good agreement with the nta good
agreement for the dry techniques and
the overall takeaway is that
espiris and tem agree and show the
particles in that condition are a little
bit smaller and both of the nta
instruments measure particle size
distributions which are not very
differentiable between the 10 and 100k
if we think of blood product mixtures
derive dbs as just a subset of a complex
mixture of nanoparticles so we know
there's exosomes and microvesicles hdls
ldls vldls tyler microns
and we measure two different
serum samples on nta we see a result
like on the left there for one and we
see a result like they're on the right
for the other when and we have a very
different seemingly amount of
nanoparticles present
these report at three times ten to the
ninth and five times ten days so five
times different in concentration
and when we combine that
now we found out the concentration
different and we combine that with the
sp iris
data we find out that the main driver of
the concentration difference here is not
actually
necessarily the 8163 nine different
particles but is driven by the arrival
of a platelet derived particle fraction
and we see the cd41a spot in the red box
for sample
that has the higher count
is greatly increased
along with the fraction of cd63 and cd9
as we'll see but the platelets here take
up a large fraction of the evs that we
see making up the difference in what's
detected on the nta
we see that come through on the cd63
probe too because the change in the pink
and the blue slice here where we're
phenotyping and measuring the number of
particles on the cd63 pad which have
cd63 and cd9 or have cd9 in the blue
so they're co-localizing those tetris
bands is greatly increased when these
platelet-derived particles arrive on the
cd63 pad with the increase in the cd9
co-localization
and we find out that the captured
platelet-derived particles so we know
that they're there because we can see
the phenotype change are actually
identical in size to what we might think
of as the exosomes making them hard to
isolate and distinguish so these three
size distributions we have our cd9 size
distribution where we had low cd41a our
c9 size distribution with high cd41a and
then the real tell the size distribution
of the cd41a capture spot which has the
platelet drive particles on it and
it's exactly the same as the
tetraspanning capture spots so
differentiating those even
platelet-derived micro particles by size
or by particular isolation technique is
a challenge and really characterizing
them after the fact is is key
this is the last
main figure i want to cover from a
really nice publication from kem
whitworth's lab where they compared the
different techniques and briefly here
the top two
packs of figures compare beads
silicon on the left polystyrene on the
right
and we see that sp iris
the rps system and the nano f7 system do
a really nice job of realizing their
multiple bead populations present so
those are measuring the size
distribution and counting the nta
systems for both cases kind of blends
this narrow peak into one and that might
not be unexpected for the resolution
with nk about 1 to 1.25 but the other
three techniques do a really good job of
resolving these particles and
for the spirit in the rps system those
are really helpful to have the our third
power dependence on the difference in
the size signal
being able to size the different size
beads is great but when we go to size
evs lower left of the four figures here
we actually find out they all look the
same and they all turn to small sizes
rps
the nano flow the sp iris all agree that
the ev size distribution is
poisson to the small sizes and the nta
kind of takes a
it kind of approximates there a little
more sense of the bigger particles so
the shape's a bit different
um
and then
when we can phenotype these for those
that can
so the nta versus spi response nanoflow
these three techniques have the
opportunity to phenotype
and
we can use both the spiritual sew up or
left chart and we have
espiris on top
and spirits on the bottom for two
different sample types and we see that
the main difference is the top sample h9
is high in cd81 finds the most cd when
most response on cd1 and then the bottom
sample is clearly negative in cd81 it
doesn't bind at all and positive for
cd63 so
we've sized
counted and can realize they're the
difference in the phenotype in a real
way something that's known about them
the other two
techniques so nta actually does uh
identify that the h9evs have a high
percentage of cd81 labeling using the
fluorescence the nanoflow here where
we've become very sensitive to the small
particles but
not it doesn't show turn out in this
case to be particularly sensitive to
differentiating this tetraspanning
signature between these because all of
the
data points to a couple of percent
positive for most of those where sp iris
really realizes the difference and the
nta in the case of the h9 clearly shows
positive cd81 particles at a high
percentage of the scatter total so
differences in sensitivity
based on the fluorescence but
the the key thing here is you have
opportunities with all of these
techniques to do phenotyping analysis
and really go from just counting
particles to identifying what those
particles are
so in conclusion we've reviewed several
commonly used single ev analysis
techniques their mechanisms sample
requirements and pros and cons and when
selecting which to apply to your
research remember to keep in mind the
needs of your question is detecting
specific ev markers
the critical parameter of the study then
you want to use a technique that really
allows you to phenotype regularly is
accurate determination of the total
particle count a key part of defining
what your product is then you'll want a
robust solution for total particle
counting identification and isolation of
a subset of particles if that's the
critical parameter counting the total
might not be useful at all so choosing
techniques which will help reveal the
valuable information your samples have
to share will save you time and effort
and i hope that you've learned a little
bit today and ask any questions you have